how did this feel tonight to come in
here you're down 18 against this team
and how did it feel to Come Away with
the victory especially after that big
shot to sen OT oh man it's huge uh like
you said we were down uh big at points
but we stayed together really played for
each other and uh you know we were able
to string string together enough good
plays to you know give us a chance at
the end sent it to OT and then uh you
know number two took over and does what
he does to OT um you know really won us
the game there Shay what you think about
This Guy's Big
Shot yeah he gave us a chance um since a
fighter every possession every play he
fights and he competes no matter what um
and his skill set took over the fight
mentality and gave us an extra five
minutes to go get the game um and
fortunately enough we did what's the
feeling going through you after that
shot goes down knowing that you gave
your team a chance uh you know a lot of
emotion obviously but last year we had a
Wizards game where he hit a big shot
like that and there was still time on
the clock and you know he was the ice
cold no emotion he knew the game wasn't
over um and you know after a few seconds
that kind of kicked in I'm telling
everybody like like we got OT so we
still got to go win this game uh
obviously that's a big shot but uh you
know the game was still going at that
point so my mind tried to track forward
to to the next moment and the next play
Shay what stood out to you about this
group to come up here win this
miniseries and sweep it yeah it was
impressive um it's a really good
basketball team everybody knows that
they know how to win basketball games
they were a little bit short-handed the
first game um they they're desperate
obviously with their losing streak um we
knew that they were going to play hard
play together um and it was going to be
a 48 minute game well in this case it
was 53 but we knew that we're going to
have to fight we're going to have to
compete the whole game before one to get
a w and we did enough for two nights to
get two W's against a really good team
thank you so much guys great
win playing some sheer Brilliance down
the stretch hren gave him a chance with
that
three